up in america's hat up in canada things
have been going really kooky lately
at george brown college in ontario
when you log on to go to a zoom meeting
for this college to take an online class
which are increasingly popular you have
to sign an acknowledgement
and you know we we have done this for
years you sign a privacy acknowledgement
when you go use a social media site they
say hey you we've got a 50 000 word
essay here where we basically say we're
going to take all your privacy away
scroll to the bottom and agree i agree
we always agree
okay if you use this service
if you submit a document this way you're
going to
acknowledge and agree to these things
okay boom boom scroll down agree well
this new
agreement that you have to use
is a little more ideological it's a
little little more woke
before you log on
you have to acknowledge
this sacred land
on which george brown college operates
they say it has been a site of human
activity since time immemorial this land
is the territory of the huron-wendat
mrs saugus
anishinabe and the hao deno saucy sauni
not saucy the territory is the subject
of the dish with one spoon wampum belt
covenant that sounds like something made
up in a liz warren cookbook but that's
real you have to acknowledge that an
agreement between the hadeno sunani
confederacy and the confederacy of the
anishinabek and allied nations to
peaceably care for and share the
resources around the great lakes we
acknowledge all treaty peoples including
those who came here as settlers as
migrants either in this generation or
generations past and those of us who
came here involuntarily particularly the
africans as settlers of the displanted
we benefit from the colonization and
genocide of the indigenous peoples it
goes on and on and on just saying we
acknowledge we're terrible we're
terrible people in canada and we've got
to give the land back to the washa
hashahushi who we're not even going to
acknowledge took it from the halamana
nabi but but forget about that it was
fine when they conquered each other it's
terrible when our guys conquered them
and we acknowledge this
and you have to agree
what if i don't agree with that
i don't agree with that i don't think
it's a terrible thing that the christian
west came in and conquered the new world
i think that's a good thing i think it
was good for the people generally there
was some it was bad for some of the
people but it was broadly speaking it
was good
and i think it's good for the world that
america now exists and i just think i
think it's a good thing that's fine i
think it's much i think it's much better
when when the english conquered the new
world than say when the comanche
conquered the apache right i think
that's good
but i have to agree to this
in order to take the class now
they they have a little disclaimer at
the bottom they say by selecting i agree
you are indicating your acknowledgement
of this statement our intent is not to
impose agreeance but to inform through
acknowledgement they're saying we're not
making you agree you just have to click
a button that says agree but don't worry
it doesn't mean that you have to agree
but do you agree agree agree
and in a in a world in which things are
increasingly online in a world in which
we're accessing education online where
we're accessing community online where
we're exercising our political rights
online
the people who control those online
platforms are going to be able to get
you to agree and if you don't go along
with their increasingly radical woke
demands you're just going to be shut out
it's not even just a question of the
ideology it's a question of the power
who's got the power who can make you
press that button and are those the kind
of people that you think should be
ruling society i certainly
do not
speaking of land disputes this happened
last week or two weeks ago but i didn't
have a chance to get to it i do want to
get to it
isis
plotted to assassinate george w bush
by smuggling assassins across the border
so an isis operative who is living in
columbus ohio
sought to smuggle terrorists through the
u.s mexico border to kill bush this
according to an unsealed fbi search
warrant
application there are lots of questions
here one apparently the feds were in
contact with this guy
so that that's good at least we don't
know sometimes it seems like the feds
are just inciting people to commit
attacks like you saw in the plot to
kidnap gretchen whitmer up in in
michigan but maybe the feds here just
act actually intercepted this and jumped
to the aid of george bush and arrested
this guy
we are seeing third world country kind
of stuff here we are now seeing a border
that is so weak so porous
that
our own presidents could potentially be
assassinated
globalism is not working out very well
the promise of globalism is there are
not going to be any borders
there are not going to no borders to
trade no borders to politics or
citizenship no borders for anything
we're all just going to kumbaya we're
all going to become one culture we're
just going to give it up all of our
particular aspects of our particular
culture everyone's interchangeable with
everything else and we're all just going
to live in one happy world where gdp
increases and that's all that matters
it's not working out very well
you're seeing intense political
instability as a result of this up to
and including the potential
assassination of our own presidents
you would think
that
the libs would get the message
you would think that that would wake
people up oh didn't work out the way we
thought it was going to for you i'll
give you another example for years
politicians in both parties said a
rising china is good for everybody
let's support china let's let china into
the world trade organization let's
encourage trade with china because as
china becomes more powerful that's going
to be good for the united states
some people thought this sounded good in
theory joe biden spread this theory and
then it turns out it's not true
okay so what happens when you realize
it's not true what do you do do you
change your behavior or do you change
your beliefs
you do you
you just you you remain
stuck
you don't do a damn thing if you are
these lips they say okay never mind la
la la i'm going to ignore what's going
on i'm going to ignore popular uprisings
against our regime here
i'm going to ignore rising nationalist
and populist sentiment and as it grows
i'm going to try to suppress them and
i'm going to call them terrorists and
i'm going to let crook lawyers off the
hook for rigging elections and i'm going
to do everything i can not to change
based on the facts on the ground it's
the same issue you've seen with will
thomas i'm not even going to make the
argument anymore that a rising china is
good for everyone i'm just going to
enforce open borders through sheer
tyranny of will
you're seeing the popular reaction
against this
just look at the race in arizona we've
had blake masters on this show blake
masters is a senate candidate in arizona
and he is running
a
socially conservative campaign
he's running a campaign where he says
americans should be able to raise their
family on a single income i love that i
think that's great
he ran a campaign ad where he said i
don't think that the 2020 election was
fair i think it was rigged
i don't think biden really won fair and
square you're not allowed to say that
but he said and i like that he said it
that guy is surging in arizona i believe
he's now leading the race
take note all you republican politicians
this is
the future at least in terms of what the
people want
that is what the people want
that is not what the ruling class wants
that's not what the people who are
writing up the agreements that you have
to agree to on tech platforms want
that's not what these self-appointed
oligarchs want that's not what the davos
set wants
when they're trying to reset our
political and economic order
you got to pick a side
you can either suck up
to the
elites who want to ignore the will of
the people who are who are still pushing
this outmoded completely discredited
idea of globalism of the idea that
that particularity is is awful
or
you can see which way the wind is
blowing i think blake masters is totally
right
i'm so glad you like that clip now you
know what you got to do you got to smash
and ring and bang and boom and zip and
hit the bell and do the subscribe so
that you can get notifications when all
of my videos come out you can also go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts leave a 75 000 star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you